so this season ends on a really good
cliffhanger
hi
how do you let me in
okay
what can i help you with
[Music]
[Music]
like what was your reaction when you uh
read how this season was going to end
and how does it set up what we can
expect season four uh my reaction when i
read it for sure was
okay expect in five minutes a call from
jaren
will be screaming yelling freaking out
to brace yourself so yeah a lot of yeah
after every time like i read one of the
scripts jaren tends to call me and i was
like oh this one's going to be an
intense reaction
but i was like whoa i didn't know okay i
love that yeah every single time no
matter even if it gets sent to our inbox
at like two in the morning i love that
he's a grandpa that sleeps way earlier
but i'm still up anyways but anyways
um yeah i was honestly jazzed just
mainly more about the fact that it's
davey
on her own terms i get a choice you know
living her own dream in her own time and
to me
that's pretty epic
i gotta tell you y'all i feel like at
this point i'm more invested in davey's
love life than my own there's just
trust i am too mine's not distant
do either of you feel like you live
vicariously through davey because i know
like i was not as lucky in love in high
school
i definitely i do yeah i mean this
season in particular
she's got majority she's got straight-up
games
and it's like very very vicarious yeah
the debut of daxton was unreal your
social status has skyrocketed so much
that now people hate you you used to
make that face all the time not on the
ground tough gig huh my three this
season tough gig with all these boys
around you no it is i it is actually a
really tough gig for um andrew um you
know darren and jaren to not fall in
love with me that is very good
i want to take some time to acknowledge
that it is really hard for them to just
come up to my level you know oh yeah
i get it you know what's really
interesting is when i asked the cast who
they think you know ultimately should
end up with davey they said it changes
for them every season
the season one i was team band he's in
two team packs in season three
i'm trying to remember i think i'm still
team paxton season three okay season one
i was team davey
season two team paxton season three team
bed so i have no idea whose team i'm on
anymore
i'll ask you guys the same question uh
do you flip flop two uh each season and
if so are you more team ben or team
paxton season three i mean i always like
a short attention so i was like like a
new new love interest yeah you know and
so to me it was like on a rude was
pretty exciting yeah for me i'm all
about just like
keep it going let's see what happens
next
yeah like yeah we don't want stability
yeah
yeah she's so young she should live
right yeah you should live but i do i do
like to like you know egg on my friends
specifically my grandmother and my
brother uh when they debate team paxton
or team ben and i like to like give them
defensive arguments for both to let them
debate i do like to see you know all of
those courses online
i'd like to see your grandmother and
your brother she is intense she is
diehard team ben my brother is die hard
team paxton i love you
so they're split it's a household that's
split yes yeah that's how i feel
sometimes too but uh you know this
season though not a love interest but
deacon philippe joins the show in his
first exacting debut uh mindy how did
this cameo come about
well you know reece had told me that he
was interested in performing and i you
know i've known deacon for a long time
and i we had this role that seemed
like just really good for him and he's
just the most
he's super talented obviously really
handsome but just like
here's this kid who's been raised by two
very successful actors and he had such a
like he wanted to learn i mean he came
to set he really wanted to learn from
our cast and you know and i just like i
just like loved that energy and he's
just such a great kid and like so
reese's son you know like incredibly
grateful
and um
just a really nice energy to be around
yeah he was really cool to hang out with
on set and just yeah really kind and
chill yeah he totally blended in with
the rest of the cast which was awesome
davey this season there's a lot of
growth with her especially when you
think about you know where this whole
show started which was her grieving the
loss of her dad uh mindy how important
was it for you guys in the writer's room
to to kind of carve out that path for
her and maybe not just make it about
all these guys around her but make it
about her
you know the romance is obviously so fun
and we love
like we love those sexy situations and
all the like awkwardness and all the
observations about that but you know
ultimately
you know when we made this show we
wanted it to be about a young woman who
is gone through
some trauma and have her heal and there
are setbacks and then there's times when
she you know does a lot of growth and so
that is the most important to me and
that's why
you know it's so joyous to have my tree
playing this part because she's so funny
i mean in the first episode alone which
i wrote there's so much physical comedy
and there's all of that but it is like
these moments with her dad or with her
therapist played by the wonderful macy
nash where you get to see
what is underneath the layers of like
ego and fronting and trying to be cool
like what what what she's about and she
gonna be okay so that's the most
important part of the show for me yeah
yeah it's definitely a team davey season
right yeah it was beautiful to watch and
so funny too um mindy you have said that
this series is loosely based on your own
life so as a mom including of one
daughter do you feel like this show has
prepared you for those teen years um
i hope not
there that this isn't you know that my
my kids are more
sort of uh nerdy my my daughter has a
big personality so there is there is
some of that i think
the one thing i don't think i don't know
like davey has so much romance going on
that i think that that probably maybe
won't be as much of an issue and i
really like that like she's a confident
character you know she's constantly
being told that she has all these
shortcomings and problems and she's like
i don't care i should be with spider-man
who's the guy who plays spider-man tom
holland tom holland
so she fully believes that tom holland
will at one point date her and they'll
have a romance so i i like that in a
young woman especially a young woman of
color and so if my daughter can have
that confidence i would be happy well
speaking of confidence davey's mom had a
lot of sharp one-liners and season also
grandma as well um are you like that
with your own kids mindy
me uh
no no because they're
my daughter just like is not having that
war so it would just it wouldn't even be
received by her
um but
yeah she's the one who's sort of doling
out the zingers at this point maybe when
she gets older i'll be able to like keep
up with her a little bit more i have one
you're a mom
like your mom is very funny and i my mom
has sharp one liner zinger does she yeah
she's very oh yeah too oh yeah she could
roast me to the straight to the sun
i i dish it back but my mom
she's got it i think i think you're
going to get it when maybe so cruising
around like it is such a great their
bond is so tight but her mom is just
also like
she's like the antithesis of the monitor
she's like got her own life going on and
like and i can say this like can check
you sometimes yeah
yeah you can check me right the love is
like so like the love is so it's really
a very nice relationship